اذا كنت من هواه صيد الاسماك ربما عليكم
وسط درجات حراره قاسيه البروده
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منه
عادات وشعر
هنا في بحيره
من البحيره
الاليه تعتمد على حفر ثقب كل 13 الى 15
مترا على طول حدود منطقه الصيد وتستلزم
العمليه حفر نحو 300 حفره لتكتمل خطه
ايقاع الاسماك في الشباك رئيس الفريق يرسم
خطه الصيد على مساحه تبلغ نحو كيلومتر
المربع هذه الشباك الضخمه بما تحتويه من
اسماك يتم سحبها عبر رافعه تجرها
ادرجت هذه التقنيه الفريده في الصين عام
2008 كواحده من عناصر التراث الثقافي غير
المادي في الصين اصطياد الاسماك في الجليد
تقليد متبعا في العديد من الدول في
استراليا مثلا
اكثر من ثمانيه الاف شخصا حضروا الى
البحيره اقتباس الجائزه الكبرى قبل اسبوع
من الحدث
من الاسماء
على جوائز متعدده تبدا من 100$ الى 300
دولار انتهاء بالجائزه الكبرى التي تبلغ
50,000 دولار تقريبا
يا هوندا
[موسيقى]
ماشي يا مجنونه شلون هويته
وخبرات الصعيد لكنه يتعلق بالحظ بشكل كبير
شاركونا اراءكم هل ترغبون في حضور
مهرجانات صيد الاسماك في الجليد